je crois que notamment les jeunes c'est
bien qu'il vienne ici maintenant est ce
que ces bâtiments tels qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui peuvent rendre compte de ce
que ce qui s'y passe et je ne crois pas
du tout 1994
simone veil se rend dans le camp
d'auschwitz des années après la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale l'émotion est
toujours intense les plaies sont encore
ouvertes dès les années 1980 les
premiers voyages scolaires étaient
organisées aussi vite devenu lieu de
mémoire
quand on voit cette cette immensité et
aucun bruit autour et on est là on
contemple et c'est là qu'on se rend
compte de la réalité parce que
finalement qu'est ce qu'on est venu
faire et 6 et 7 face à face avec une
vérité qu'il a fallu accepter ces
voyages scolaires sont un moyen pour les
jeunes de comprendre l'histoire
autrement que par les livres comme
l'expliqué cette lycéenne en 1989
voyage je représente toute une prise de
conscience beaucoup plus forte que ce
qu'on avait étudié dans les livres
d'histoire dans en classe
en 1990 la profanation du cimetière juif
de carpentras entraîne une véritable
prise de conscience la sensibilisation
des jeunes à la déportation semble alors
nécessaire pour ce journaliste de
l'époque le programme scolaire ne suffit
plus au programme d'histoire de classe
de 3e la seconde guerre mondiale mais
sur le sort réservé au peuple juif
pendant cette période les manuels sont
peu bavards
quelle que soit l édition de page une
photo un croquis et de ligne seulement
pour expliquer le génocide
les années 2000 enregistre une montée
des actes antisémites une des
conséquences en 2004
le tout nouveau mémorial de la shoah a
organisé un voyage scolaire à cette
occasion les élèves étaient accompagnés
par un ancien déporté du camp jules
fainzang les jeunes on se rend compte
qu'ils sont très intéressés beaucoup
plus intéressant quand ils nous écoutent
avec beaucoup plus de force avec
beaucoup de volonté de savoir ça ça nous
donne beaucoup de courage chaque année
plusieurs milliers de lycéens partent en
voyage scolaire à auschwitz dans le
cadre d'un partenariat avec le mémorial
de la shoah malgré cela 21 % des 18-24
ans n'avait jamais entendu parler du
génocide des juifs selon un sondage en
[Musique]